(upbeat music)
- So you voted for yourself?
- Absolutely.
- Some of us have situations
in which we need to help people
and I'm saying this a 100% serious.
(people chattering)
- This is a competition.
- I don't ever cry.
- Well we know who we're voting for so.
- Thanks for coming everybody.
(dramatic music)
- Welcome to Stacks the show
where every vote counts.
Today seven strangers must
decide who gets to keep $1,000.
The players will have
four rounds of discussion.
After each round, there
will be blind voting.
One gold brick equals one vote.
At the end of the game,
the person with the tallest
stack wins the prize.
This is Stacks.
(upbeat music)
(cash register chiming)
- What's going on?(sniffs)
Wait y'all smell that?
- What?
- That's a smell of money
you're about to make.
- Oh hell yeah.
- Okay.
(contestants laugh)
- Oh see this?
- [Narrator] Round one each
player will get one gold brick.
They'll have six minutes to discuss
who they think should take the cash prize.
- Let's get into discussing.
Ready go.
(clock beeps)
- I mean I think we can all agree
that a thousand dollars would help almost,
if not everybody in this room.
We're definitely paying rent.
(contestants chattering)
- Yes, bills...
- Which is coming up.
- I'm not gonna lie to
you, if I win the money,
I am gonna buy some weed.
'Cause those taxes-
- Oh, hell yeah.
- LA, it's stressful.
- Anybody like, pursuing
something that they,
their hopes, their dreams?
- I went to college for screenwriting.
You'd be supporting my art.
Black, queer art.
I was like, "Hm, maybe they'll
support a struggling artist,
sob stories immediately."
Not sob stories, but tearjerkers.
- I currently share a room with my Lola,
which is Tagalog for grandma.
And I love her to death
but she also has a lot
of hoarding tendencies.
So I'm really, really trying to move out.
'Cause it's been taking a really bad toll
on my mental health.
- Girl, I imagine.
- I am from Venezuela.
We moved here escaping from the government
and my grandma's still there.
And every time she has issues.
She doesn't have food to eat,
or her house has fallen
down because of rain.
She calls me and she,
like she needs that money.
- Well, damn, okay.
(contestants chuckle)
- I definitely need to
pay back Capital One.
They want their money
(contestants laugh)
for their credit card.
Chase wants their money,
Capital One wants their money.
Like, I gotta give it to them so.
- I'm in a lot of debt.
Which is crazy for like,
an accounting major.
I majored in accounting,
but I can't account for (beep).
Like, what's going on?
Why is it like this?
- I work from home,
but they're making me go back
in the office in one week.
All I have is a bicycle and
my work is like, 10 miles.
So that's gonna be a lot of
hustling if I don't get a car.
- I think outside of basic
rent and living necessities,
I would budget it towards
my future performances
or, you know, getting myself to work.
Gas is not cheap, so.
- Energy's not cheap either,
I have to ride my bicycle.
I'm just kidding.
(contestants laugh)
- I respect your strategy.
I respect your strategy.
(contestants chattering)
- All right, time is up.
Thanks for discussing.
It's time to vote.
(suspenseful music)
- [Narrator] Each player will vote
for who they think should win the prize.
But there's a catch.
If all seven players vote for themselves,
the game is over, and no one wins.
(suspenseful music)
- I definitely understand the struggle,
and I have a soft spot for my grandma too.
So, yeah.
(suspenseful music)
- (beep) everyone else.
(dramatic music)
- She said that her aunt's roof
was dropping in Venezuela.
Like, come on now.
I'm gonna give her the money.
I have to vote for her.
(suspenseful music)
(gentle music)
- My legs hurt, I need a car.
(suspenseful music)
- I don't think everyone
here is stupid enough
to vote for themselves.
So I'm gonna take the bet.
Hopefully it doesn't bite me in the ass.
(suspenseful music)
- Please open your eyes
in three, two, one.
Open.
(dramatic music)
(energetic music)
- So no one voted for me?
(contestants laugh)
- So you voted for yourself?
- Absolutely.
(gold clinking)
- All right, let's get into round two.
This one, the rules are
going to change a little bit.
- [Narrator] In round two,
only players who currently have stacks
will receive two more
gold bricks for voting,
but all players can
participate in the discussion.
- You have four minutes this time.
It's going to keep going down, maybe, so.
Shall we?
- Let's do it.
- Let's go.
(clock beeping)
- So just, like, so we can,
like, pick apart some of your brains,
what would you use the money
for, like, fantasy wise?
And not bills, not cars,
not gas, none of that.
Like, what would you buy for fun?
- For like a necessity
or to help somebody out.
- We know no one's helping
anyone out with the money so.
I'm just kidding, I'm kidding.
- I was like "Boy".
- Okay okay okay!
- Zach, uh- uh.
I was like, "Hell no".
Okay. This is all for ourselves.
And I was like, "Excuse me, sir.
Like, no talk for yourself."
- No, I was surprised
that no one wanted to play
like aggressively.
I want to win the money.
I want to win all the money.
- I don't know, a better camera?
I'm trying to get a YouTube
started, but that's just...
(contestants laugh)
- Sorry, I got emotional.
I swear, I have like the worst luck.
And this morning I was in Mammoth
'cause I have, like,
really bad depression.
So my roommate told me to,
like, get out of the house.
Sorry,
I mean I was in her car driving
and I hit a patch of ice and I hit a car.
And so now on top of not having a car,
I have to pay to fix hers
and the person that I hit
and I don't ever cry.
(contestants chattering)
- This is a safe space. There's
queers here, don't worry.
- Can I hug you?
(contestants cross talking)
- Yeah, we all gay here, bro
- I'm sorry.
- No, it's okay.
- Well, we know who
we're voting for, so...
- Thanks for coming everybody!
- Except we don't have any bricks,
so we can't even vote.
- I never cry.
And I'm embarrassed that I
cried in front of everyone.
- Anybody else have a story for us?
- My Lola right now, she's
kind of, like, soiling the bed
and I share the bed with her.
It's just really hard 'cause
I just want a nice place
to stay and have that concentration
for school and everything.
- What do you want to do for fun?
What do you want to spend it on?
- I would probably do a fun
vacation with my boyfriend.
What would you do?
- Honestly? I was gonna go shopping.
I'm not gonna let you,
I was gonna go shopping.
- What about the dad though?
- Yeah. What happened to the dad?
- Well, you're saying
if it's like, fanciful
It's 'cause I'm for fun.
- If the debt wasn't there...
- If it wasn't there, I would go shopping.
- Oh, right. This was supposed to be fun.
We were supposed to be having fun.
A little chat.
- [Narrator] For this round,
players can use their two gold bricks
to vote for any player.
Even those without a stack.
- See, I'm a nice person.
(suspenseful music)
- I love my grandma way too much.
- I was really torn, but I just
kinda have to pick strategy.
But I also really wanna help out Gloria.
(suspenseful music)
- I know how hard it is
to take care of someone
you love, that's not well.
So I wish the best for her.
(suspenseful music)
- So I'm voting for myself again
because I don't wanna struggle.
But also I feel for Gloria, girl.
but I might have to be the villain here,
and vote for myself a couple times
so, I can stay on top.
- [Man] And in round two, you
gave it to yourself again?
- That, (laughs)
but I didn't give both of them to myself.
I gave one to someone else.
So it didn't look
suspicious because it did.
People were sussing who gave
one to themselves, you know.
- If you could lift your
eyelids in three, two, one.
(dramatic music)
- Well at least y'all are back in.
(contestants laugh)
- Yeah!
(gold stacks tingle)
- So before I explain this,
please don't and hate me.
For round three, you're
gonna be casting your vote
on who you think should
lose their entire stack.
Three minutes for this?
Set, go.
- Well, my votes were strategic.
I voted for YouTube back in the game.
- Oh my.
- So, not trying to be
like mother Teresa here.
(contestants laugh)
I'm just saying the three of us.
We're a team now forever.
- Don't let that blind you.
- I will say too, three of
you have four bricks each.
Clearly, not all of you are gonna win.
So I think realistically,
one of those gotta go.
- Interesting.
- I'm just being honest here.
Not all three of you can win.
- You haven't lied. You haven't lied.
- I think the three of
you should hash it out
- It's so hard!
- Do we agree?
Do we disagree?
- It's a hard job!
- I did not have the heart to do that.
I can't sabotage them.
Like I would feel horrible, so...
- Of course, we all are
human beings, we're selfish.
We wanna fend for ourselves, you know,
but some of us have situations
in which we need to help people.
And I'm saying it's a one 100% serious.
- No, I know
- One 100%.
- Of course.
- Research Venezuela.
You will see what the
(beep) is going on there.
- But not all three of you can win.
- Yeah, of course.
But I'm just saying that like,
if we are in this position right now,
it's for a reason
and I feel like, okay, you know what?
Then one of you have to go just
because maybe you are lower.
That's selfish.
- All three of you can't win the money.
Like it's, it's gonna
come down to one person.
So I was just playing on like
strategy and who could I team up with.
- In defense of my tower, my little tower.
So y'all don't any ideas.
I drove all the way here from Chicago,
in my little 2008 Solera,
it's on this last breath.
I don't know how many more it can take.
- Well you should have told us that...
(contestants chattering)
- Your stories are so sad, I was like
oh, mine's nothing compared to this,
but I do live to a, like, live next door
to allegedly at meth lab.
Maybe it'd be easier, I don't know,
to knock off the little single ones.
- What if y'all just fought for it?
- Okay.
- Just kidding. (laughs)
- Time is up.
It's time to vote.
(suspenseful music)
- [Narrator] Players who
currently have stacks
will vote for who they think
should lose their entire stack.
- How much time do I have?
(suspenseful music)
I'm gonna vote for George,
because he got one brick.
- Even though this is a game,
these are real people
with real world problems.
(suspenseful music)
- I just let faith take this one.
And by faith, I mean
eenie meenie minie mo.
I'm so sorry.
(suspenseful music)
- Three, two, one. Open.
(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] Zach lost his stack,
but now has the opportunity
to redistribute his brick.
He can give his brick to anyone
who he thinks is deserving.
(suspenseful music)
(dramatic music)
- Zach gave his to Edi.
- When he gave me his brick,
I was like, "Damn, I just
voted you out, bro." But...
- I don't know. I liked
her vibe. She was nice.
Me and her were talking (beep) the most.
So I guess like she became
my friend. So (laughs)
- But alas, we got our last
and final round, round four.
(tense music)
You only have two minutes for this one,
and I'm not gonna tell
you the rules for voting.
Okay. Let's go.
- Well, (beep) all you guys.
- Okay.
- I'm sorry.
(contestants chattering)
- I don't even know.
- I didn't vote...
- It's a game. We all got ran.
I'll just go, you know, cry in my car.
- Okay. But I think since
this is the last one.
The three of us should
probably take our last step
and say our last little thing.
- Yeah, take center stage, girl.
- As far as like resources go,
I've been really researching
all the resources I have
and I'm actually reached
out to emergency housing
at my school.
And so that's how I plan
on finding the housing and everything.
And also I am trying to find
a better quality psychologist
because the one that I had was a free one
and he like gave a diagnosis
after like an eight minute phone call.
- So I actually was in the process
of buying a car this past week.
I could only buy like a car
with like a hundred thousand miles on it.
And I went to a mechanic to look at it
and they were like, this
car's really messed up.
Don't buy it.
So I spent like $300.
So I'm like, even more in
debt than I was before.
- Give it to us, Ed.
- Yes, I will help my grandma,
but I'm also in a lot of debt.
So this will like help me out.
This will give me some peace of mind
to not have to like, work
my ass off so (beep) hard
to like, help myself and also
her over there, you know.
- Here is the rule that I kept from y'all.
We're not giving you any more bricks
- [Narrator] For the final voting rule,
players can move one brick
from any stack to another.
Only players who currently have stacks
are allowed to vote.
(suspenseful music)
- I'm sorry. This is just a lot.
I'm like, whew.
(suspenseful music)
- Okay. Maybe he isn't so bad.
(tense music)
- I feel so, so, so bad.
But I really, really, really need this.
(suspenseful music)
- I don't think I'm gonna win.
So, might as well cause
some chaos and discord.
We'll see what happens. I don't know.
- All right, please open your eyes
in three, two, one, open.
(dramatic music)
- Ooh. Sudden death.
- I lost.
- Wow.
- I just, you know, wanted
to make it interesting.
Cause some mayhem.
Well, I did. (laughs)
- So, we actually are going
into a special tie breaker round.
Two of you that have the highest stacks
have to fight for them, okay.
Not physically, right?
- [Narrator] Pheebsa and
Gloria will get 30 seconds
to state their case.
- Since I was 17, I've been
financially independent.
I've been working for
everything that I have,
and just this money would
really really help out
with moving out and being able
to have my own independence
and having being able
to find the balance that I
really really need in my life.
- Like anytime anyone has any problem,
I'll stop what I'm doing
to go give them money,
give them some time, anything.
And during the pandemic,
no one did that for me.
Any help that I can get, even
if it's just from Jubilee
would be nice from you guys helping me.
(tense music)
- [Narrator] Players who
currently have stacks
will move a brick from their stack
to the player they think should win.
(suspenseful music)
- Go get it girl.
- In the tie breaker
between Gloria and Pheebsa,
the results are in.
If you will open your
eyes in three, two, one.
(contestants clapping)
(upbeat music)
(cash register beeping)
- Oh my Gog.(laughs hysterically)
Thank you guys!
- Congratulations.
- I'm so happy!
- Pheebsa, there you are!
Check this bad boy out.
- Thank you!
- (laughs) How do you feel?
- I feel really good and
really bad at the same time.
- I'm glad she won,
she deserves the money,
but like, anyone should be
able to have a fair chance.
I thought it was like,
I was like, okay,
I'm a bitter (beep) in the background now.
- Some people are not as
bad as they seem at first.
Zach really surprised me.
So even though I didn't win, I feel good.
'Cause I was surprised.
I was reminded that, "Hey,
don't judge so quickly."
- My biggest lesson right
now is to put yourself first.
I feel like that's the only
way, you can kind of win
in this life is to be selfish sometimes.
- I feel honestly just like
really, really, really relieved.
I'm just really appreciative
of the opportunity
and I just like, don't wanna (beep) it up.
(upbeat music)
- Okay. That's it for this episode.
Thank you so so much for watching.
Congrats again.
(laughs) You look great with it.
- Thank you!
- You're wearing green
pants, you got green money.
- I know I... (squeals)
- It's yours, who cares?(laughs)
Stay tuned next time
and see if somebody else gets
a higher stack than today.
(gentle music)